the next inductee honest Alex on his
show he will speak for himself but all
of us know alex has one of the nicest
guy in chest nicest guys in chess
one of the humblest self-effacing
despite all his many successes alex is
also an Iron Man maybe the oldest player
in the field but I think he's the best
best athlete in the room as he runs
several triathlons Alex congratulations
it's a really beautiful honor and please
welcome it's a few words
[Applause]
reaching 2700 rating has always been
that it would be cold for me and when
for the third time in my life I got a
rating of $26.99 I started to get a
little bit worried my whole chest
carrier was very much like that I have
to fail several times before I would win
a big tournament when I was tying for
first place I was always second on a
tie-break I really had to work hard to
to to stay competitive and this is the
great owner and this is the greatest
accomplishment in my life to get
inducted into the Hall of Fame my family
my father and four of my sisters they
play chess and there are pretty good
players and all these years they've been
so supportive
my wife Olga when I was a professional
chess player I used to travel a lot she
was studying working watchin over the
kids and I know for the fact that how
hard it is because now I'm doing all
these things all the time being on the
national team has always been a
privilege and many of my teammates here
in this room today we always have the
best coach the best Captain John Watson
a very good friend of mine and I'd like
to thank you guys for it was for the
privilege and also it was the greatest
time I had when while playing chess I'd
like to thank all Lauren's ow
invited me to Texas Tech
I have six wonderful years if not for
Rex and and Jeanne I would quit just a
long time ago and because of what you
have done for the us shares I stayed in
chess and I don't have these thoughts
anymore I really enjoy they're all being
the oldest player in the championship
and well I'll keep on fighting and
trying to to qualify for this
championship as as long as I can well
again thank you very much everyone and
there's a even like I said a few years
ago I love you all thank you
[Applause]
[Music]